ساعه نسال جونكر بالان الذي يعود الينا
منسق شؤون الاتصالات في مجلس الامن القومي
اهلا بك معنا سيد كاربي اذا كنت تسمعني
جيدا هل هناك مبادره امريكيه حاليا لوقف
اطلاق النار في السودان
من قبل وزاره الخارجيه يتراسها السيد
بلينكل لتمديد لوقف اطلاق النار في الايام
المقبله لقد راينا تخفيضا في اعمال العنف
التي طالت كافه انحاء السودان لكن هناك
بعض المناطق التي لا تزال فيها اعمال
العنف لكن مع ذلك تراجع العنف ونعمل بصوره
حديثه للتواصل مع الطرفين من اجل تمديد
وقف اطلاق النار هل استطعتم التحصل على
موافقه الطرفين على تمديد الهدنه التي
تنتهي بعد ساعتين من الان الاثنتين وسبعين
ساعه اخرى
على درايه بالاجل النهائي للهدنه الحاليه
ونعمل مع الطرفين المتحاربين الجنرال
البرهان والجنر الحميتي لتمديد وقف اطلاق
النار لان هذا هو الامر الصائب الذي يجب
فعله من اجل الشعب السوداني ومن اجل
الرعايه الاجانب الذي الذين يعيشون في
السودان وكذلك للاحتياجات الانسانيه في
السودان هل مبادرتكم منفصله عن مبادره
الايجاد او جهودكم بالاحرى هل هي منفصله
يمكن ان اتحدث عن جهود اخرى تماما او انكم
ترحبون بمبادره الايجاد
اننا نرحب بمبادره ايجاد او اي مبادره
اخرى من اجل وقف القتال وادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه الولايات المتحده توسطت في وقف
اطلاق النار الذي شهدناه على مر الساعات
الاثنتين وسبعين الماضيه واننا سعيدون
لرؤيه ذلك لكننا بكل تاكيد نرحب بجهود
كافه الحلفاء وشركاء من اجل احلال السلام
في السودان ان لم يحصل ذلك وان لم يتفق
الطرفان في وقت مبكر هل
تهددون بامكانيه فرض عقوبات على احد
الطرفين او على كلا الطرفين
انا لن استبق الاحداث والخيارات التي قد
نتبعها او لا نتبعها لكن ما استطيع ان
اخبرك اياه بان التركيز في الفتره الحاليه
ينصب على وقف القتال
واستمرار وقف القتال بحيث يمكن ادخال
للمساعده الانسانيه والناس الذين يرغبون
بالمغادره بمقدورهم فعل ذلك وكذلك الضمان
عوده السلم والامان للشعب السوداني هذا ما
يبحث عن الشعب السوداني وهذا ما نريده لهم
لكن التركيز الان ينصب على وقف العنف
طيب هل تتفهمون هل تتفهمون اسباب الحرب
التي يعلنها كل طرف من الطرفين طرف الجيش
وطرف قوات الدعم السريع
هل لك هل تتفهمون في الولايات المتحده
الاسباب التي يقول بها كل طرف حول
محاربته الطرف الاخر وقوه دعم السعوديه
الان توافق على الهدنه تفضل
سوف ادفع اتركه الجنرالات لتتحدث عن
وجهاتي النظر والاختلافات فيما بينهما
وحول كيفيه التعامل مع الاوضاع في السودان
من المؤكد ان لكل منهما رؤيه مختلفه حول
مستقبل السودان بمقدورهما التحدث عن ذلك
لكن بالنسبه لنا نرغب بوقف العنف والقاء
السلاح بحيث نستطيع ان نحقق السلام
والاستقرار لادخال المساعدات الانسانيه
للناس المحتاجين اذا كان الطرفان
المتحاربان يهتمان البته بمستقبل السودان
فلابد لهم من وقف السلاح من القاء السلاح
ووقف القتال وايجاد ايجاد السبل لاثقال
الغذاء والمياه والمعدات الطبيه والتحول
الى سلطه مدنيه في البلاد
يسال ما الحكمه الامريكيه في المساواه بين
طرفي القتال بينما الجيش السوداني هو
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وهو النظام
السوداني القائم حاليا واتهاماته للطرف
الاخر بانه اشبه بمليشيات لماذا تساوون
بين الطرفين
اود ان اوضح هنا اننا لا ندخل انفسنا
ولنزجوا بانفسنا في هذه الحرب
بل نسعى للتفاوض
في الفتره الحاليه الى تسويه في الفتره
المستقبليه وما نسعى للقيام به هي مساله
بسيطه ان نطلب من الطرفين المتحاربين
العمل على وقف القتال وان يلتزمان وقد
التزم الطرف الطرفان بوقف القتال في
الساعات اثنتين وسبعين الماضيه وقد انخفض
مستوى العالم لدى من غير المقبول اذا ما
كان هناك
سعي لوقف اطلاق نار دائم فلابد من التحدث
الى الطرفين وليس الى طرف واحد هذا ما
نعمل عليه ما الدور الذي تقوم به السعوديه
في هذا الاطار وهل هي المرشحه الاكبر فعلا
لاستضافه فريقي النزاع سيد البرهان ويعني
زعيمين الفريقين سيد البرهان وسيد حميدتي
على اراضيها لاجراء مفاوضات هل يمكن تاكيد
ذلك
من المؤكد بانني سوف اترك شركائنا
واصدقائنا في السعوديه للحديث عن ذلك
لكنهم قد ساعدونا الى حجم كبير في اجلائي
مواطنين امريكيين وقد ساعدوا ايضا
في اجلاء اعداد كبيره من الرعايه الاجانب
عبر بورسودان وقد تكون السعوديه وقد يكون
السعوديه دور مهم في اجلائي اعداد كبيره
من الاجانب واننا ممتنون لما تقوم به في
هذا الخصوص شكرا جزيلا للاتصالات في مجلس
الامن القومي من واشنطن تحياتي اليك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات